[Music]
mat
mat I don't really have that passion for
passion but passion for passion have you
heard this statement that passion for
passion some people just have it you
kind of have that passion for passion
you're good like you you have a sense of
it I I I mean I don't think this stuff
really matches but like it's more like
the colors no you P together you have
cool shoes that kind of does isn't that
just work all magic you can be wearing
like PJs whatever
but if like but if your shoes if the
shoes are then they oh they know what
they're doing oh they trust me that
whole thing it's ironic you know they're
yeah
mainly you wear what oh
yeah check
check yeah let me uh get this
checked all right thank you
friend
[Music]
CH it up hey
Gary hey
Gary check check test
testing test one one two one two
three this is my niece this is
Shiloh yeah okay it was Cyrus is that
right Cyrus I love your I love your hair
it's a good that's a good
look got that top knot
going cousin has the same thing in his
hair mhm check check one two one two he
test test 2 three check check one check
two check
three test one test two what
up check
everybody's oh outside yeah che che
well am I muted now they said they could
hear me out there huh they said they
could hear me out
there
[Music]
yeah
Christian
[Music]
oh
hello everybody I was going to ask if
y'all could hear me but I can hear
myself so I think we're good how's
everyone
doing
how's everyone
doing slightly better but we'll take it
uh my name is Miriam for those of you
all that I don't know um would love to
meet you all chat with you all
um kind of get an idea of who you are
and and you know how you found us and so
on I love to make conversation people
always joke with me and say I can talk
to a tree so it's very true I can talk
to you know have fun talking to whoever
so come find me after this um I'd love
to chat with you um and leading into
that we do have if you're not familiar
we have our monthly meal together first
Sunday of every month we go meet at hat
Creek yes hat Creek I always have to
look at the address I live all the way
up in Anna so I don't know where this
place where the the street name so off
of Highway 78 in
saxi just type it in on your phone I
couldn't tell you how to get there from
here just type it in and you'll find it
but immediately after we'll meet there
um just have have fun you know eat
together it's a very kid-friendly place
if you have kids or if you're just a big
kid yourself there's a play place and
you can go play and have fun great food
and fellowship um we are doing a table
census so essentially what that means is
we're just trying to get an updated
address phone number all that
information from people um I filled out
one myself this past week even though I
didn't move I just wanted to make sure
everything was updated on file and it's
not so we can harass you or send you
anything um we just want to know who you
are where you're from and then a big
thing is we kind of gear our meetups to
that as well right so like I said I live
up in Anna doesn't really make sense for
me to go all the way down here for a
Meetup so I go to one in Allen so just
kind of figuring out where people live
so you can scan the code up on the
screen behind me in front of me um or
you can go online I believe I don't have
the link um scratch that never mind um
Easter Service this year is going to be
held on this Saturday before Easter and
that is March 30th so put that in your
phone put it in your calendar it'll be
at 5:00
p.m. um we realize we you probably don't
want to be here 5:00 P pm on Easter so
we're going to do it the the evening
before we'll have service here and then
immediately following we're going to
have a soup and bread potluck style meal
in the Family Life Center so it is the
building in the back of this property
you're welcome to come uh we would love
to have you there so make sure to mark
that in on your calendars so before we
go ahead and get started
with soup and
bread hot luuck style yes we bring our
own right is okay
yes yes make enough for
everyone soup and bread we're gonna
we're gonna have full bellies after that
yeah all right I'm going to lead us into
uh a lint prayer so if you would um you
know however you you feel comfortable
bow your head close your eyes but I'll
lead us in this prayer before we go into
worship merciful god you hate nothing
you have made and unfold in your love
all who turn to you create and make in
us new and truthful hearts that are
guilt and wretchedness may open us to
your forgiveness which brings us new
life through Jesus Christ Our Lord who
suffered shame and death to show us the
extent of your love
[Music]
amen thanks so much if you guys want to
go ahead and stand with us we're going
to get started with our music tonight um
we're going to sing out good God so if
you guys want to just follow
along Joe's going to be leading the
repeat in that or you can follow me on
the melody part but we would love for
you to just sing out this is um a space
where we get to lift our voices a space
where we get to as a community agree
together that God is good he is faithful
he's Dependable he is for us he's not
against us um so that's what this time
is here for so I just invite you to
enter into it as you're
able
all right let's sing be still
ready be still my
soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know my God is
here be still my
soul be still my soul
be still know that my God is here all
that I need to know is this you are a
good god maker of heaven
call you are a good God and your heart
beats in my chest you are a good God all
that I have to do is rest you are a good
God
[Music]
all right let's sing I won't be
afraid I won't be
afraid I won't be afraid my God is
here will make a
way he will make a way he will make a
way my God is here all that I need to
know is this you are a good god maker of
heav calls me hands you are a good God
and my heart beats in my chest you are a
good God all that I have to do is rest
you are a good
[Music]
god let's sing you gave you gave me your
right you gave me your heart your spirit
flows through my veins you gave me your
eyes you gave me your heart your spirit
eyes you gave me your heart your SP
flows through my veins you gave me your
eyes you gave me your heart your spirit
flows through my veins oh you gave me
your eyes you gave me your heart you had
a plan right from the start I know who I
am cuz I know who you are you are a good
God all that I need to know is
this the maker of heaven calls
me
all that I need to know is this you are
a good god maker of heav calls me you
are a good God and your heart beats in
my chair you are a good God all that I
have to do is you are a good god yes you
are a good God you are a good God you
are a good God you are a good
God all right you kids can meet your
teachers over at the doors line up
behind them and they will take you to
your classrooms and we will see you
after the service thank you so much kids
ministry
team Chrissy Katie Maggie
Britney appreciate all you
[Music]
guys all right as they move on out we're
going to transition to prayers of the
people so um I see a couple new faces so
I'm just going to go ahead and and lay
out sort of how this portion of our
service goes for those of you who may
not have been with us before um this is
uh a tradition that's been present
throughout Christian history um and it's
one that helps us to kind of practice
the art of remembering that Christ is
with us in our pain that he wants to
share in that with us and we want to
hold that space for each other we want
to shoulder those B burdens together so
we're going to read through this prayer
out loud um all of us and then we'll
leave some space for anyone who would
like to speak out a name or a situation
that you're carrying into the room
tonight that's weighing heavy on your
heart um someone that you're remembering
in prayer you can just speak that out
loud if you're online with us you can
write that in the comments and um then
we will close out the prayer again
together so let's um read along on the
screen
Jesus for this city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to
you
[Music]
Johnny
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
amen
[Music]
oh good shepherd would you teach me how
to
rest I'm rushing on will you make me to
lie down
will you build a fold By the Waters that
refresh will you call my name and Lead
Me safely
out anxious tribe to labor On and
On from the Restless grind that has put
my mind to
sleep
will you call me back and gently Slow Me
Down Will you show me now what to lose
and what to
keep oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
[Music]
Down When my tables bent with only greet
and gold
and my grasping hands are afraid you
won't
provide Will you pour the wi the loosens
of my
home set your table here with what truly
satisfies oh good
shepher oh good
friend so me
down slow me
down oh good
sheph oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down on the busy streets trying to make
myself a
name if the work is yours there nothing
I can
claim if you lead me home to the
pressures of your
peace oh the house is yours I'm sitting
at your
feet oh good
shepherd oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me Down oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down
[Music]
you know it's hard to slow down if we
don't believe that God is with us and
for us moving in and all around us even
when we're not even when we're not even
we're sleeping you
know that's what this next song is about
it's about Christ being our firm
foundation and that's why we can slow
down that's why we can slow down rest
so let's sing this
out Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I stand
everything around me
shaken I I've never been more glad that
I put my faith in
Jesus he's never let me down he's
faithful through
generations so why would he fail
now he
won he won
I've still got joy in
chaos I've got peace that makes no sense
so I won't be going
under I'm not held by My Own Strength I
buil my life on
Jesus he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
season so why would he fail Now sing it
out he
won't he
won't he won't
fail he won't
fail he
won't
he
won't he won't
fail he won't
fail he
W pain when blue my house was built on
you I'm safe with you I'm going to make
it
through rain came when blue my house was
built on
you I'm safe with you I'm going to make
it
through oh I'm going to make it through
cuz I'm standing strong on
you I'm going to make it
through my house is built on you Christ
is my firm
foundation The Rock on which I stand
everything around me is
Shen I've never been more glad I put my
faith in
Jesus he's never let me down faithful
through
generations so why would he fail
now he
won't he
won't he won't
fail
he won't
fail he
[Music]
won't he
won't God you are
[Music]
reliable we can count on you to keep
showing up to keep loving
us to keep shining your light in our
darkness and God when we can't trust our
feelings which are like sinking sand I
pray that you and your truth would be a
rock beneath us that you would be a firm
foundation that we can build our life
on would your love the scaffolding of
our
life the
unchanging the
constant the everpresent
[Music]
we love you Jesus and we celebrate you
tonight we celebrate being able to come
together in a community who wants to
pursue love who wants to look for love
wants to find it
and not the kind of the world that comes
and goes but yours that remains that
stays true that is firm beneath our
feet we love you it's in Jesus name we
pray
amen thank you guys for worshiping
together with us if you want to turn to
the people around you welcome them make
them feel comfortable and at home and
then Brett will get us started on our
message good job
y'all well Grace and peace it is uh so
so good to be with you all so I'm glad
to be back um I was out last week and uh
just on vacation I mean I was just
chilling I wasn't even doing I wasn't
doing anything spiritual or anything
just out and uh it was yeah a delight um
but I am I'm glad to be back with you
all and uh to welcome you into this
space and as always that includes those
joining us online y'all are not
forgotten love you lots and um anyone
here tonight who is new um thank you so
much for for being being with us um
maybe it's your first time or just first
time in a long time and we're we're just
glad we're just glad you're here um so
we are in I guess this is week three of
lint but it's um week two in our series
which is titled lint with Julian of
Norwich so let me unpack a little bit of
this so lint is for those unfamiliar I
know not everyone grew up with like the
whole church calendar thing if you were
um maybe
Catholic uh you grew up with it um maybe
Anglican or other Mainline denominations
Methodist Lutheran you were familiar if
you're coming from that Evangelical wing
of the church ah maybe not so much and
uh so lint is um this season of kind of
contemplation reflection um repentance
healing it's really a time of um well
preparation is good work because it's
getting us ready for Good Friday right
the day of the Cross and then onto
Easter Sunday and um I personally I've
really enjoyed starting to follow the
church calendar the last few years it's
really only been since we started the
table that I've done this and uh there's
something about like I don't know like
Easter at least in theur tradtion I came
from like you know we just I don't know
we hummed along we're doing random
series and things and all a sudden it's
like
Easter you know I mean we just kind like
oh it's here okay Hallelujah he you know
I mean didn't even die I don't know I
guess we missed Good Friday like we
didn't we didn't even do Good Friday you
know um or sometimes weirdly the pre the
preacher would try to feel the need to
try to do both you know kind of like oh
it's well crucifixion and Easter you
know because they're trying to cram it
all in together so I like lint it gives
us some space you know like let's let's
let's let's prepare let's prepare so uh
that's kind of the the heartbeat of lint
and so we're doing this with the title
is lint with Julian of Norwich and uh uh
Julian was a um a Christian Mystic um
she lived in Norwich um which is like
100 miles or so Northeast of London way
back 1343 to like 1416 or sometime
thereafter um we didn't have good
records people didn't know then that she
would be like this famous so you know I
didn't like keep super accurate records
but um Julian she was a remarkable so
she wrote a book um where she had these
kind of mystical visions of Christ and
uh and so she wrote them down it's
called Revelations of divine love um you
can find mirabi Star has written a
wonderful translation uh of these very
readable um and so in it though we're
kind of we're not trying to do like a
survey of the book or anything we're
just focused on this like one little
it's almost like just a few pages where
she unpacks this Vision she has where
she she names them it sounds a little
bit um
kind of uh I don't know well it's very
lenti in that it's the seven Great Pains
of sin some translations of her even
have the seven Great like miseries you
know so it's a very you know kind of
medieval Christianity but honestly
Julian I've said is everyone's favorite
Mystic because even though that can
sound a little bit intense like her
vision of God and I mean just it's so
unbeliev passionate and just all that
it's it's wonderful um but this Vision
so what does she see she says she saw um
this this image of like a a servant
because again 1343 so she her whole
imagination is like you know uh queens
and Lords and knights and you know all
that so she sees this this servant who's
standing next to their lord and she says
so the servant is like an image of
humanity the Lord of course is God gives
the servant a task the the Ser so eager
to run off and fulfill the Lord's will
but like within you know just a a few
hundred feet almost immediately the
servant she says falls into this deep
pit
hit and and there experiences what she
calls the seven Great Pains of sin and
so it's it's funny like interestingly in
her um yeah in her vision it's all kind
of accidental you know which is part
compassionate which to that more next
week um where it's like you know she
doesn't even want to say like we did on
purpose no she's like we accidentally
fell into the pit you know which is
sometimes true but sometimes not but um
anyway but that's you know she's very
compassionate that way so this Ser yeah
Falls in and um there so in week one we
talked about the bruising how s like it
just leaves us feeling like beat up so
that was kind of week one um tonight
that the title of the message is
alone alone Julian um she writes these
words she says the sixth so this kind of
jumping ahead the sixth was the pain
that most astounded
me he lay there
utterly
alone
I think we have to keep in mind the
allegorical kind of nature of this
because taken too literally it's of
course not shocking at all you know like
well of course you're like out for a
stroll and you fall into a hole and
you're alone it's like surprise you're
in the hole alone you know it's like of
course but but remember it's a it's a
picture right it's a
picture of the way that kind of our our
own tendency to kind of like Miss the
mark and mess up and it just it can end
up with us feeling so incredibly
isolated and so I think Julian's
astounded here right because she's not
astounded at the other sins so to speak
n at no other point does she say like
and that one astounded me too like nope
it's only this one that she just can't
but she's not astounded at the bruising
um next week we'll talk about she's not
astounded at like the tightness and
difficulty of the pit itself and what it
teaches us like not to stand at that no
what she's absolutely floored by is like
oh my gosh look at that poor creature
like he's so hurting and just
alone that's what she's astounded
by and um I I think this actually makes
sense if you if you reflect on it
because she's astounded for the same
reason we are when like have you ever um
known someone and you knew like they're
going through a really hard time they're
really
struggling and it was it was obvious
that they were struggling even though
they hadn't told you anything but you
just
knew and yet even as clear as it was
like in essence everyone around them
kind of knows they're like not doing
well you know what I mean but they think
they're doing such a good job of hiding
it you know what I mean and maybe you've
been there yourself like Oho yeah I know
how to keep my cards close to my chest
you know what I mean but really like the
people in your life who know you are
like you're not doing good you know and
and I think it's in that it's that same
astounding where we can see someone else
and it's so clear like oh my gosh
they're going through it like please
reach out please say like I need some
help I'm in the pits you know like
please but what
no nope nope nope nope nope
nope this is what I'm going to call the
strangeness of humanity in Our Moment of
deepest need need what do we
do we withdraw from
others in our time our season of
greatest pain we
isolate it's remarkable isn't
it I think that's um that's my kind of
interpretation of the why why Julian's
astounded at this this pain amidst all
of the
others um you know to kind of understand
this I want to contrast this kind of
loneliness with what I'll call like um
normal loneliness not normal as in good
or fine but just normal as in sort of
the a normal experience of this I was
doing some research and um there's
something like it's kind of high it's
honestly a little disturbing something
like 80% of those under the age of 18
describe feeling lonely like fairly
often um so 80% which is a lot uh and
then 40% over the age of 65
describe feeling like pretty consistent
feelings of loneliness so what you kind
of what the research seems to indicate
is we have this sort of Arc um where we
feel lonely in our younger years and
then it kind of recedes as we kind of
approach middle age maybe it's the you
know height of like work and perhaps
family or whatever um and then of course
you can see where kind of retirement is
age or somewhere around there you know
it starts to pick up again um but what
this what I'll call normal loneliness is
kind of the it's like the social
equivalent of um like hunger or thirst
in other words it's this kind of
god-given
drive to connect you know like in the
same way you get hungry and what do you
do like I'm going to eat some food right
it's this sort of god-given this this
internal thing or you're thirsty get a
drink you know and in the same way feel
lonely connect you know like reach out
send a text make a call hey let's get
coffee hey let's get a beer hey let's
you know whatever like it's there's this
you know it's this natural drive now can
you see like with that in mind where the
where the pit starts to get us can you
see where all of a sudden we've got a
problem right when when hungry we eat
when thirsty we drink when lonely we
connect but th like this is the the
danger the the kind of
perniciousness of of um of of sin of of
like the the pit it's not even just
about Sin so much I'm going to say it's
like it's the pit of um guilt it's the
pit of um shame the pit of
condemnation it's the pit of humiliation
and stigma right it's it's precisely
those feelings which is more than just
sin but it can often accompany when we
feel like we've done wrong and we're
like super ashamed about it you know
that it's those it's that constellation
of feelings
that ends up
undermining our natural normal kind of
reaction to like oh my gosh I'm feeling
isolated it's time to reach out like you
can see where we're having the feelings
of like oh no oh no I'm in the pit I
should reach out I ought to reach out
I'm feeling internally like I kind of
need that but
uh I can't I I'm it's like a I'm
trapped I I can't I I can't I can't open
up you know at at that level I can't I
can't share that I can share this but I
can't share that with others can can you
see where this ends up uh causing this
astounding loneliness in our
lives it kind of reminds me of the uh
Netflix show
alone anyone fan of alone dude it's so
good uh for those unfamiliar the whole
idea so it's like a Wilderness kind of
Survival show um you know they're kind
of I guess I I've picked this up later
so all these later Seasons it's always
cold I think they figured out that when
they were launching these contestants
into the jungle those people could live
too long like they're real good at this
you know what I mean they're like sure
fishing there's tons of fish I'll just
do this forever you know so they're like
we got to wrap this game so now they
throw them into like Alaska Canada and
we're going to throw you out there in
September late September you know so
it's like winter is coming you know it's
that kind of thing so um these contest
but here's the trick right uh they're
they're super Adept at like braving the
Wilderness so they can I mean if they're
hungry they can fish and trap and Hunt
there people they're amazing you know uh
if they're cold people are like weaving
clothes and I mean it's just crazy but
the twist for the game is right in the
title the trick is they are
alone they're alone and if you I found
it utterly imposs possible to ever
predict who will win like at the
beginning you're think like oh that she
knows she's good you know that guy oh I
think they're going to but the thing the
craziest crap happens like it's just
they they step in a rock and it's like
oh my ankle and that's it game over you
know just with the ankle like because
they don't have anyone right who's like
okay okay hey let's get you a splint and
don't worry you rest here we'll wait for
that to heal I can do that you know I
mean nope they're
alone and and it's not the phys physical
kind of aloneness and something bad
happens they don't have help um
sometimes
just it's just the mind they're super
Adept they're so skilled and they know
all the things but the
aloneness gets them every
time just messes with them and they have
food for days but they tap
out and isn't the it the aloneness that
gets us
too it's just like we can handle almost
anything you know when hungry we eat
like we got especially in the modern
world like we're we lack for nothing but
oh goodness it's the aloneness that gets
us and and here's what's surprising it's
it's not even though as simple as we'll
just have some friends or we'll just
have a family or someone you know a few
people that love you and that's enough
like this is what's weird is you can be
with others you can be a part of the
table and still feel what
alone like what how can this be I was uh
looking into this I found these authors
and researchers Lis hawkley John cipo um
they're psychologist and professors of
neuroscience at the University of
Chicago they've like done all the
research into this and uh they put it
they kind of summed it up this way they
said people can live relatively solitary
lives and not feel
lonely and conversely they can live an
ostensibly Rich social life you can tell
they have their phds there right
ostensibly Rich social um and feel
lonely
nevertheless loneliness is defined as a
distressing feeling that accompanies the
perception it's not the reality but the
the perception that one's social needs
are not met being met by the quantity or
especially here's the key word the
quality that's the word for tonight not
just the quantity the quality
of one's social
relationships reminds me of uh Proverbs
chapter 18: 24 a person of many
companions may come to
ruin but there is a friend who sticks
closer than a brother or a
sister in other words Simply Having
people many
companions doesn't
guarantee you won't still feel utterly
isolated and
alone even surrounded by
people uh reflecting on this same kind
of theme and uh Julian's um sixth great
pain Richard Beck put it this way he
said we want to lean on each other but
oh we're unsteady
Partners we don't love each other as we
ought and this is the trick the kids are
unwell and so are the parents the
husband struggling so is the wife the
church members keep their secrets so do
the pastors your friend is falling apart
and you can't keep yourself together
perhaps then the pit isn't so lonely
after all we're just all in the pit
together amen right and but here's the
trick right but but why is that because
that's the thing even saying we're all
we are all in the pit
together yes but even that doesn't solve
the problem in essence even if we all
agree aren't we there we are is your
life perfect no neither is mine you know
like we're all in the pit
together but that's kind of the trick um
or I guess it begs the question what's
the key to that
quality what's the key to kind of shift
to
where you not only have people but you
actually don't feel so alone anymore
what might change
that I think in the end it's it's about
vulnerability it's about opening up it's
it's about
sharing not just what happened that day
like how do you feel about what happened
that day you know or you can go to a
Meetup and you can be like well this
happened in the week and that and this
and that you know but I mean it's it's
okay it's okay that's different then
this is what happened and honestly this
is how I feel about it I'm kind of
brokenhearted about
that I'm kind of messed up about that
I'm not feeling great at all about that
you know like there's got to be this
this kind of um uh a will kind of um
opening and opening up right because
that's the key you can be in the pit
heck you could be a part of a small
group a meet up at the table and be all
in the pit but it's no
there pretending that they're
not because then we're just all in the
pit together feeling as lonely as ever
but the key is when you're there in the
pit and you say hey hey can I just be
honest I'm just I'm just not I'm just
not doing well this this week this day
this situation whatever it is it's
eating my lunch
struggling like all of the sudden the
the Breakthrough begins to
happen in short we could say that the
light of
vulnerability dispels the shadows of
loneliness especially when you feel like
you're in the pit but I think this is
danger is that too often in Christian
circles we're willing to share the amens
and the praise the Lords and the
Hallelujah but we often grieve and we
suffer
alone that's the I would say that might
just might be the tragedy of maybe not
just the American church maybe just
church in general is that we're there
for the halls and we're there for the oh
the breakthroughs and the you know even
as a pastor you're kind of tempted to
just share about the breakthroughs and
the oh let me tell you how great
everything is in my life you know and it
just but what happens we we just end up
grieving and suffering alone
because because coming back to what we
knew at the beginning because of that
that pulling
away I going to read this quote this is
from Diedrich Bon Hoffer his wonderful
book life together he says it may be
that Christians not withstanding in
other words like in spite of all of and
he lists all these practices in spite of
all of the corporate worship and common
prayer and all their fellowship and
service may still be left to the their
loneliness the final breakthrough to
Fellowship does not occur because though
they have fellowship with one another as
Believers and devout people they do not
have Fellowship as the
undev as
Sinners the pious Fellowship permits no
one to be a sinner and so everyone must
conceal his or her Sin from themselves
and from the fellowship and so we
remain
alone with our sin living in lies and
hypocrisy it's heavy huh it's heavy but
I'll tell you
um as you begin to open up and
share the the
breakthroughs the breakthroughs you can
begin to have it's it's it's something
special it's something
beautiful lifegiving
to like just let the guard down I just I
think
um yeah we just to protect ourselves get
those walls you
know and there's something so beautiful
about just becoming vulnerable into
opening
up I've had this experience in my own um
Meetup I got permission to share some of
these stories um I meet with some guys
on Saturday mornings at roses in Wy it's
a good time it's early 8: a.m. and uh I
I I tell you I love we we are kind of
part book club part share so we always
have a book we're reading um and I love
I love the book club part I'm a nerd you
know what I mean so I'm like yeah I like
their ideas and the guys in the group
they're very smart and they have
wonderful insights and all that it's
it's great um but I if I'm honest I
think the the place where I have learned
the most from them is in the this area
of vulnerability and um
emotions and expressing what it is
they're feeling and why they're feeling
it it's absolutely astounding I mean
honestly I wasn't surprised as they
began to share and they would reference
conversations with their therapist and
uh I was like dude I knew it like
they're they're just so good at like
articulating stuff I'm like do y'all go
to therapy they do their therapists
would be so proud um I need to give a
shout out all the therapists like you're
just doing we have a few at the table
like you're doing such good spiritual
work just helping us yeah can we give
them a hand
like it's it is it's like and don't
think of it as like you know I heard one
Professor who's also a therapist he put
it this way he said there's no such
thing as secular therapy you know like
well are you going to the Christian
therapy or secular because the spirit is
there you know what I mean like the holy
spirit is there and working I mean
wherever how could God not be in a place
where you're like okay it's time for me
to get real you know like how could God
not be there right all right back to my
original story so there we are in these
mornings and they're just sharing so
beautifully and I've been reflecting on
some of these stories there's one man
for example um gay man parents very
fundamentalist he came out a while ago
um but just the relationship with his
parents again I got permission charless
um it's just so contentious and
difficult and he's just he said he just
finds himself week after week he is
trying his best to walk this out with a
certain a a Grace and a love for them
but but on the backside like the
feelings of
betrayal and and just plain grief that
he feels he said like it's just it's
just freaking crushing like it's just
almost at times more than he can bear
and he has come at times close to like
do I just need to set a hard boundry of
like no more I'm just done you know um
but he's he's by Grace he's kind of
finding a way to maintain some
relationship while trying to walk it out
you know I'm just astounded week after
week as he shares this these stories
another man he's um new to the corporate
world and I he's like totally triggering
things in me as I reflect back to being
in my 20s I had left the pastor I was in
the corporate world and just he's
describing the pressure he's under and
I'm just like oh gosh I could get sweaty
just thinking about it like it's just
the office politics and the butt
covering when something's going wrong
and then he feels like he's going to get
blamed for a thing he's worried about
Los in his job I just you know he's
sharing all of it and I'm just like man
I feel for you brother like it is just
it is it's incredibly difficult another
man shares um he said I'm I'm learning
that it's okay to be
angry that's what he said I'm learning
it's okay to be angry and then as he
shared it turned out not just angry in
general like and he didn't mean lose it
on people and scream at them he didn't
mean that he said but to feel the
feelings he said um because as as a you
know male he his anger in his younger
years was scary to people so he kind of
learned like clamp that down don't feel
that so he that he did a lot of stuffing
you know and so he said specifically I'm
learning that actually I have a lot of
anger at
God I'm learning to be angry at
God
and that may sound strange I think
that's holy work why because it's
honest it's honest and that's like the
whole thing with Christian Life is
honest that's the whole thing about
being in the pit
honesty about what you're feeling why
you're feeling it it's it's
beautiful and then me I share um about
my o not just overwhelm but the
what happens when I get in Stress and
Anxiety
mode and the stupid things I say and
do when I'm in that
mode and it just freaking eats my
lunch and I'll tell you as we're there
and we're sharing it's not like and then
all of a sudden we're all just out of
the pit and we're like we're delivered
and it's over and we just prance out of
roses just like wo you know it's not
that easy like we're in ways we're still
in the pit but you know what we're not
in the pit
alone not in the pit
alone so I guess um the truth is as
Julian norwitch the writer of Proverbs
Richard Beck Dietrick bonhoff are all
name you know we're in the pit we are
but boy we're in that pit together so
why not open up I guess that's my
encouragement to you tonight why not
open up why not give it a
try and just might we find God's grace
as we slowly begin to Journey
out in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of
Christ in the wine we we do this as an
act of reconnecting with the
compassionate god with with the one who
loves us and made us and who sees us in
the pit and longs to be with us there
and to by Grace slowly lead us
out and so um as you come forward
tonight I I pray that it's it's like a
little moment of reconnection of opening
up your heart uh to God to others again
to feel what you're feeling um so the
way we'll go about this tonight we'll
just start kind of front row we'll just
go row by row and work our way back you
can just come right down the the middle
here and form um one line we will have
uh folks too folks serving the the cup
so that way you can kind of Branch off
and you know go in the direction you you
need to go um you should know that the
red is wine real wine
yeah we're edgy uh the white is grape
juice so um just don't be shocked you
and um and finally we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you want to participate
regardless of denominational affiliation
or your theology or whatever you know um
you're welcome to to participate so this
is the table not of the church but of
the Lord and it's made ready for those
who love him and for those who want to
love him more so come
you who have much
Faith you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the
table
[Music]
l
we're going to close out tonight with a
song that if you've been around the
table this is kind of one of our staple
songs I like to call them um it's
actually entitled come to the table um
and I feel like what Brett was sharing
tonight this song can be an invitation
to us not to just show up you know I
mean which which is part of the battle
right it's just showing up being in the
same space together for sure um but it's
it's more than that really being a part
of the table is choosing vulnerability
choosing to open ourselves to to attend
a Meetup to take that risk to be in
relationship with each other in a real
kind of way not just a yeah I'm doing
fine how are you fine great okay good
but but to share our hearts share our
pain um to hold that space together like
we do um in prayers of the people to
really um Let each other in so tonight
as we sing this let's let's accept it as
as the invitation calls to us let's step
in and let's engage and um maybe take
that next step even if if it's just in
your heart right now towards you know
vulnerability so would you guys stand
with me as we close out tonight
and let's sing This Together sing with
me come all proud come all greedy come
all liers come all shamed come all
wealthy come receive it to the table
come and
stay come all broken come all
needy come all por come our
slaves come our rulers come be
seated come all Sinners Come All Saints
come to the
table come near and
far come from the
[Music]
Shadows come out of the
dark there's room at the
table we saved you
a come to the
B come join in the
Fe every r and every nation come all
Rebels come all day from the bres come
to Jesus to the table full of
grace to the table come and say come to
the
table
[Music]
come there's no Inner
Circle come D with the
King recline at the
table come let down your
God you're never
stranger just come as you
are come
behold
Oh Come Be
Love come
accepted come now
come come
behold come be
love come
accepted come now
come come
[Music]
[Applause]
behold come be
L come
accepted come now
come prepare is the
table we're ready to Fe
the party is
waiting there's
defe the Harvest is
[Music]
ready go fill and
receive go live out the
Miss as a kingdom of
priest go live out the
as a kingdom
[Music]
priest test test there we go um what a
beautiful song I remember hearing it for
the first time in July of last year
Jesse was actually leading it and I
can't tell you the last time before that
moment that I felt something in
church and I feel like a lot of us here
maybe have gone through situations that
we have felt
unwanted or we have seen people
neglected in the church that
setting and some a line that sticks out
to me in that song is come be whole come
be loved come
accepted just like Brett
said we love you the good bad the ugly
all of that and we're not meant to be
alone and I hope that you all know
you're welcome here as I always
say I want to thank you all for coming
here this evening uh if you are new to
the table especially a big welcome to
you all if you could um scan that QR
code we also have little cards to your
right on this table over here just to
kind of let us know who you are again in
no way do we want you to feel alone um
we want you to know that we're here for
you and connect with you so if you would
do that that would be great if you're in
need of a hug a prayer high five word of
encouragement come find me come find
Brett really really anyone here um and
we'd be happy to do that and give you
that
love here at the table we are committed
to creating an inclusive Christ centered
community in order to do that um we do
need support from our community and from
our members as well so if you feel led I
will encourage you to again either scan
that QR code or fill out a card over
there if you feel led to give to our
mission in doing
so don't forget um we do have our
monthly dinner at hat Creek immediately
following this service um if you're new
and you choose to attend come find me
I'll be there um I'll be heading there
immediately after I'd love to chat with
you and have a nice meal with
you and then I want to send you out with
my favorite part of every service the
benediction so you can receive this um
in any way that you please hands out
eyes closed however you are comfortable
in
doing you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and this is true on
your worst day so as you go into your
week ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are are
are accepted just the way that you
more and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of Grace and unconditional
love to everyone that you come in
contact with be blessed hope to see you
at hat Creek if we don't catch you there
we'll see you next
[Music]
week come
behold
come be